Speaker 1: Let's see how to even introduce
this next story.
It's become a popular talking point.
Now that we are 20 ish days or so into the
Russian invasion of Ukraine.
It's become a popular talking point for defenders
of the former President Donald Trump to say.
Putin didn't do this under Trump.
He's doing this under Joe Biden because Trump
was strong and Putin respected Trump, whereas
Biden is weak and Vladimir Putin does not
respect Joe Biden.
And when in the past I've talked about this,
I've said to you, that's speculative.
That's that's completely speculative.
Trump has never been seen as particularly
strong by any world leader and.
Russia and Putin preferred Trump over Hillary.
So it doesn't really make sense that Russia
would prefer the stronger person, they would
probably prefer the weaker person, it just
sort of makes sense.
So it was kind of a speculative claim.
And when I came to you and talked to you about
it and I said, Sirs, servicers and M&Ms.
And I said, that's a that's speculative.
And if we want to speculate, it's much more
plausible to me that the reason Russia didn't
invade Ukraine under Trump was because Russia
didn't feel the need because generally they
were more pleased with what the international
community spotlighted on the United States
was doing with regard to Russia at the time.
They're both speculative, but one conforms
to the facts much more closely now.
You can even go further in that analysis and
say it's not even really true that Russia
did nothing to Ukraine when Trump was president
because they maintained their their presence
in the Donetsk and Luhansk and continued supporting
the separatists there.
OK, so it's like not even really true.
But among speculation, it made more sense
that the reason Putin didn't do more when
Trump was president was because he didn't
really feel that he needed to because he was
more pleased with Trump as president.
OK, we now have a new perspective, and it
comes from Donald Trump's own former national
security adviser John Bolton and John Bolton
says Putin saw Trump doing a lot of his work
for him, so he chose not to invade Ukraine.
Bolton's opinion matches much of our speculation.
Business Insider goes on to say Trump considered
withdrawing the U.S. from Naito while he was
president.
That's something that is very, you know, Putin
likes that.
Bolton said it's one of the reasons that Putin
did not invade Ukraine during Trump's time
in office.
And it really makes perfect sense.
This was our suspicion, and it makes a lot
of sense now.
I think I would be doing an incomplete discussion
of this if I didn't mention John Bolton, Bolton's
despicable.
Of course, and I know that the revolutionary
left any time you say, Hey, the CIA says this
or Bolton said that they say
Speaker 2: you
Speaker 1: corporatist establishment stooge
believing what these people say uncritically.
No, we're not doing that.
It's natural and correct to see John Bolton
as a despicable person.
One of the great architects of the war in
Iraq in 2003.
All of it.
Of course.
Of course, of course.
And he screwed around during the impeachment.
He could have testified, but he opted not
to.
And he has personal knowledge of how disastrous
Trump was.
And now all of a sudden, he's sort of like
giving us the goods.
But at the same time, you can understand that
reality about John Bolton and still recognize
that what he's saying matches up with much
of what was publicly known.
And it conforms to common sense as well.
Both can be true.
And so I am not someone who uncritically accepts
anything that horrible neocon, a Trump former
Trump employees say.
But I believe that it's completely plausible
what Bolton is saying, and it really makes
a lot of sense, and it was our sense from
the beginning.
Is Bolton the good guy now?
But why would he lie about this specifically?
I don't really know.
He's certainly a war hawk opportunist, you
know, piece of crap who has repeatedly lobbied
the U.S. to go to war with Iran, and he looks
out for himself, his financial interests,
etc..
I just don't think he's lying here.
I think what he's what he's saying makes perfect
sense.
He's been an enabler.
He's laid cover for a corrupt war in Iraq
and all of these different things.
But we suspected that that explanation made
at least more sense than Don Jr's explanation
that daddy's so strong that Vlad didn't invade.
That explanation did not make any sense because
Trump was not strong.
And in fact, you have to look only at the
sanctions.
I mean, Hillary Clinton has been sanctioned
and banned by Putin and Russia.
She's not president or she's not doing anything
right now.
And Trump's not on that sanction list.
So the evidence all points to what John Bolton
happens to be saying.
If you disagree with his assessment by all
means, I want to hear from you and you can
find me on Twitter at De Packman.
Let me know your thoughts.
The David Pakman Show is funded primarily
by viewers like you, podcast listeners, like
you by our community at the end of the day.
And the number one mechanism for that funding
is the David Pakman Show membership program,
which you can find it join Packman dot com.
Not only do you get the Daily Bonus Show an
extra show every day that Alex Jones really
doesn't like.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money and everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: You also get access to the commercial
free audio and video feeds of the show, and
they're available six hours earlier to our
members roughly five, six, five and a half
six five hours 40 minutes earlier than that
for everybody else.
You can sign up at join Packman dot com.
You can use the coupon code.
Wow.
22.
If you would like a discount,